hey guys today i have a quick theory
that i think is quite feasible
and it relies on the connection between
all might sukuchi and captain celebrity
who is america's number one ranked hero
the american
influence in this series is already
quite prominent uh given that you know
the us has been referred to as the hero
capital of the world
in a character page in the manga and not
to mention of course that deku undertook
the american dream plan to gain enough
strength to handle one for all
in this video i'll be explaining why he
might need to undergo
a different type of american dream plan
to master float
and all the other quirks that he's going
to get as part of one for all
just before we get into it though i'm
currently running a competition for
one subscriber to win free merch of
their choice
and all you've got to do to enter is sub
to my second channel
and leave a comment on the latest video
the winner will be randomly selected on
the 30th of september
and the link is in the description for
anyone who wants to enter
okay so as most of you know deku is in
the process of gradually unlocking all
the different quirks inside one for all
and these were originally held by the
previous users
the first power to be unlocked was
blackwhip and he started his internship
with endeavour
with very minimal control over this
quirk only to
literally one week later be holding up
three cars with civilians inside them
having already learned a great deal from
the number one hero in japan
it's possible that if certain events
play out like i'm gonna say
he'll be training under the teachings of
captain celebrity
for those that haven't seen my video
explaining this character's ability
his power is called flight which among
other things
lets him jet around town at super high
speeds both float and flight are
remarkably similar
which would make the captain one of the
most experienced people
to perhaps unlock the true potential of
float
in regular circumstances you could say
that gran torino would be the best
because you know i mean he
he trained alongside nana shimura who
originally had this quirk
and also his own quirk lets him fly too
but
if senior citizen gran torino can
survive this attack from sugaraki
then i would consider that a massive cop
out from harakoshi like
he he shouldn't be surviving this we saw
in chapter 285
that ochako is also helping deku to get
the right balance when it comes to
floating in the air
but i mean when it comes to maneuvering
around sharp corners and just flying
forward like superman
captain celebrity is the guy now i know
many of you will be thinking
why would america's number one hero
agreed to teach a random japanese school
kid who he's never met
and that is a very valid question but i
do have a few answers
firstly captain celebrity has strong
ties to japan
having lived in tokyo during his time in
the country and forming solid
relationships with vigilantes
pro heroes and most importantly makoto
makoto started out as one of captain
celebrities cheerleaders
only to work her way up to managing his
whole empire in new york
his respect for her is so immense that
he referred to her as a goddess
even in front of his own wife she's also
the sister of detective tsukuchi
who is almight's best friend and one of
the very few people
who knows about one for all that
connection is important because
with the war arc getting super intense
recently gran torino's death is imminent
and likewise almighty's death it's
inevitable like we don't know when
exactly what happened
but i wouldn't i wouldn't say it's too
far away sonata's prediction is still in
play
and you know the last time we saw all
might he was watching the fight unfold
on tv
so given that deku is in a battle with
shigeraki it's possible that all might
might go to the location to try and like
intervene because
after all he is a true hero and as we
saw in episode one
true heroes even if they're quirkless
they will always you know rush into
battle
the moment that torino and all might
both die that means that sukuchi is the
only
member of this trio who knows about one
for all and in fact he might step up to
the plate in their absence
and play a more prominent role to fill
the void left behind
deku's float quirk is now common
knowledge thanks to him activating it
on a live tv news broadcast and you know
we saw that people in the evacuated city
were watching it on their phones they
were watching the news
and sukuchi the last time we saw him
that was at the very beginning of the
war before all the fighting really broke
out
and so it's likely that he has been
evacuated himself
so because he knows about the float
quirk along with everyone else
tsuguchi can use his sister's close
connections to captain celebrity
to arrange for deku to receive this
training and master the quirk fully
it's also important to remember that the
captain has great respect for all might
after the hero literally
saved his life in the vigilante's manga
so if the symbol of peace is killed by
shigaraki as we all suspect might happen
then of course he's going to agree to
train almight's successor
if requested to do so by one of these
sukuchi siblings
as fond as he is of japan i doubt
captain celebrity himself would get
involved in the battle
mainly because the us would wouldn't
really gain anything by sending their
number one hero to participate
in a japanese civil war as a result
training deku to utilize his float power
is the next best thing and it's just a
win-win situation all round
we all know how a young all might fled
to america to escape
all for one before growing in strength
and then returning to japan
when he was ready to defeat all for one
midoriya's story has already paralleled
all might in several ways
not least because they were both born
quirkless but with the heart of a true
hero
so you know by temporarily fleeing to
america after the death of his mentor
midoriya would just be following in
almight's footsteps yet again
but actually you know he'd be taking it
to a new level because
whereas all might was going to the us to
to build up one for all
deku's going to the u.s to hopefully
learn six different quirks
or master six different quirks and maybe
you know
after he trains with captain celebrity
maybe he could then go to a different
state and train with a different hero
who maybe has a quirk
similar to the other quirks that he
needs to unlock
i'm sure the captain could pull a few
strings if necessary
but anyways guys those were my thoughts
on this particular theory
it just came to me after reading chapter
284 so i thought i'd throw it out there
do let me know your thoughts is it
possible that captain celebrity will
finally get an introduction to the main
story
and what are the odds of deku fleeing
japan if the villains can claim victory
let me know down below and be sure to
sub to the channel
and also sub to my second channel if you
want to you know be involved in the
prize draw
until the next one peace out